how about we just start with a quick
intro cool yeah thanks for having me my
name is Laura I run a company called
Shippo we power shipping for e-commerce
what that means is we connect our
customers who are ecommerce stores
platforms and marketplaces to a network
of different shipping providers then we
help them figure out which provider to
use for which one of their packages the
reason why people care about shipping
today is that shipping directly affects
conversion rates so it's no longer just
a means to an end
to get your item from A to B ecommerce
stores they needed to be able to convert
their customers because customers are
expecting free and fast shipping
Amazon Prime has taught them that and
whenever they see shipping rates at
checkout that are unexpected or too high
they drop off and they go to Amazon to
try to find the same things okay and so
how does your customer interact with
shippo exactly so it's an API it's a
restful api that they can integrate
either they integrate the API or they
use the dashboard that we've built on
top of the API both works if you
integrate the API there's more
flexibility you can do more with that
SMEs that are just getting started that
don't have developers inhales they
typically just use the out-of-the-box
dash dash board solution okay and so
what's a what's a normal customer of
yours like like what do they make what
do they sell so a normal customer of
ours they're an e-commerce store that's
they sell products that are
differentiated they have their own brand
they don't want to sell their products
on Amazon they want to own their own
brand experience sell through their own
ecommerce store and ship typically
either out of their own workshops or
their own or a warehouse a 3pl that
takes care of shipping for them okay and
so what's a 3pl for people a third-party
logistics provider okay and did you know
anything about this stuff before 2013
when you guys started I do not Anna like
I would never have imagined that I now
know all of these things it yeah it's
been crazy I started this as like a
complete logistics noop and I got into
e-commerce by pure chance when trying to
built an e-commerce store on the site
together with my co-founder Simon we
built an e-commerce store using Shopify
it was
a really easy solution and it was just a
fun thing to do on the side and then
when we try to integrate or connect with
different shipping providers we realized
that the technology experience provided
by shipping providers was just so
different compared to the technology
experience provided by Shopify or stripe
like we the the shipping providers
aren't tech companies so they're API
documentation Zarn is great great and
intuitive if you have to be a logistics
expert to be able to read the
documentation sometimes you have to
request API access or it's a soap API it
was just strange to us that everything's
been solved except for the shipping
component and it is a frustrating
experience so we were like why is there
nothing comparable to Twilio or stripe
in the shipping industry let's give that
a try and were there other like kind of
critical understandings that you didn't
quite get in the beginning that now are
like obvious as integral to running a
shipping company yes we were learning on
the job I mean we didn't know anything
about shipping back then and we tried to
solve shipping from the customer
perspective and I think that was a good
perspective to have so we weren't
influenced by the restrictions coming
from a shipping industry we're able to
look at it from the perspective of this
is how an ecommerce store wants it to be
and this is what modern technology looks
like let's build it like that I would
say like we back then I'd say
underestimated just how different the
different shipping providers are there
like there is no standard across
different shipping providers not in
terms of pricing not in terms of
Technology they're all totally different
and building that layer of abstraction
on top was harder than expected but
that's now also a great competitive
advantage job ok because who are your
competitors right now so there are a
couple of incumbents out there like
stamps indicia Pitney Bowes yeah and
then there is another company in this
space called EZ post like that we would
consider them our main competitors or
the most comparable companies
okay gotcha so as I was listening to a
bunch of the the podcast interview done
before I've heard you talk about many of
the same things because you know like
it's obvious that you want to talk about
chipping in you're excited I'm super
excited I one of the questions I kind of
wanted to start off with then is like
what are you passionate about that you
don't get asked about a lot oh that's a
great question so I think what I would
like to do more of is traveling running
and reading okay there is not that much
to say about all these things yourself
like okay wait when I go travel I think
leaving the valley as soon as I leave
the valley I'm able to see or look at
things from a different perspective I'm
not in the nitty-gritty details anymore
I don't really care about how it's being
done operationally I can think about the
big picture and come back with great
ideas and then also just look at how
people like last year traveled to a
wedding in in the UK and there was no
cell reception in like that little
village where the wedding was people
were still living there they didn't care
like people were helps me realize how
things here in the valley are just not
think they're not normal and they are
maybe solving the problem for a small
amount of the population but that's not
how everyone thinks out there mm-hmm
yeah and we for sure want to build
solutions that are for more people than
just people living in the valley
yeah because you guys are I mean if
you're selling to small businesses right
that are like trying to differentiate
themselves and not go and Amazon how do
you reach out to them if they're not
necessarily even that technical yeah so
I would say like small businesses is one
area that we're selling into we're also
selling into platforms and marketplaces
and then anyone who wants to compete
with Amazon it can also be a bigger
business one of our customers for
instance this ebay that's on the
marketplace side but we've learned that
it's really hard to sell someone a
shipping solution if they're not looking
like it's not it's not something that
other people are passionate about right
so we typically it's more an insight
sales process when people are looking
when something is wrong something's
broken too expensive
shipping is vital enough that they do
pretty thorough research and then they
will find us at some point and when they
find us we want to capture them at their
intent and make sure that they're
finding what they want to find so like
having the right keywords having the
right landing pages and just handing
them exactly what they're looking for
but we like it's it's really difficult
to get someone excited about shipping
when it's not a need okay so before we
started you were talking about people
you know like basically connecting all
these things together now what are your
thoughts on that I mean you said it
wasn't a fully formed idea yeah but like
yeah weird what do you think no what I
was thinking is like it's easier than
ever today to build your e-commerce
store online you don't have to be a
developer there is less upfront cost
because you don't need to invest into a
physical retail location everything's
online you get Shopify you get stripe
you get like triple maybe or another
shipping provider Facebook ads
everything is out there you just connect
it together and then like you don't have
to build your own infrastructure anymore
all you have to do is find or make a
product that is differentiated enough so
that it's not like out there on Amazon
or somewhere else where people can
undercut you in terms of price and then
you need to build an emotional
connection with your customer I think
ecommerce today is a lot about
storytelling it's about like making sure
that customers connect with you and like
develop some sort of feeling or
attachment for you and then you use the
channels like Facebook Instagram
snapchat if you're like a millennial or
Gen Z or whatever those generations are
called like you use the right channels
to reach to reach your audience and you
tell a personal story to them and then
people are proud like to where I don't
know all birds or to travel with there
it's called always is it whatever that
like thing is called okay yeah and it
seems like oh and then there is the
unboxing experience like every part from
when you ship the item to when the
customer receives it like every step is
carefully coordinated you get the box
you unbox it people film themselves
unboxing it and it's it's a huge hit on
YouTube or you packages packaging is
being designed to look pretty on
Instagram so that people can take
picture
and share it with their followers yeah
so that was that was just my thought how
infrastructure is how people don't need
to invest in infrastructure anymore it's
available out of the box and how today
ecommerce is all about like getting your
customers to feel something for you to
feel attached to your product yeah and I
think we're seeing a lot of companies
both you know YC like venture backed and
not venture backed companies that are
really crushing it is is there anyone
out there that you think is doing it
particularly well you mentioned all
birds and the sluggish thing maybe
someone who's less well-known that maybe
even your customer that's doing it
really well that you can like you can
point to a reason why they're successful
yeah so I think glassier is pretty well
known as well do you talk about glossy
or something less well known I think
they're good everyone knows about them
yeah I mean glossy or is this a makeup
company and I think and I know her story
Emily's story just from reading about it
I think she started as a blogger just
creating a great following with unique
content online and then when she had
that following and people were like
looking at her as an authority in the
beauty blogging space she was able to
launch her own beauty line and that like
on Instagram the pictures are beautiful
it's all it's I think it's that the
product the packaging looks like it's
designed for Instagram when I get the
box you open it there are stickers in
there there's a little pouch in there so
stuff that I didn't order that she's
giving me for free and I'm excited about
it and I see people posting about it and
on Instagram people are engaging with
the blockquote
with the posts in the Commons and she
gives out referral codes so people keep
talking about and refer their customers
their friends I mean and then they also
oh they reblock or regram yeah I'm not
I'm not up to date with all these like
fancy terms but they regram if i post a
picture of glass here they will and it
gets a lot of likes they might regram it
on there
professional site so I am incentivized
to like post something so that I can get
more followers if they regram it it's
yeah it's I think they're doing a
phenomenal job just making sure that
their followers are being engaged on the
right channel so channel set their
active on and that it's not that
corporate like it does not when I look
at their their site it I don't get a
corporate feeling I get the feeling that
it's a girlfriend telling me about
makeup so it's working like you're in
the demographic get it working on you oh
and the other thing is like you can't
find it on Amazon you can't find it
anywhere else except for on their site
and that's the great part like if you
sell a product that is too generic
someone else can sell it on Amazon and
it's easily replaceable or
interchangeable and then Amazon has some
like you have Amazon Prime so you save
on shipping it's convenient and you just
get everything on there mm-hmm
is anyone I'm trying to think of a good
example of someone doing well on Amazon
and outside of it like I don't see a lot
of that mega brands I what I'm seeing or
what I hear from friends who run
ecommerce stores is they have tried
Amazon as a channel but it's basically
just cannibalizing themselves and it's
not they prefer to keep their own brands
or to be able to manage their own brands
on their own websites to have to create
that experience to create the feeling
and the loyalty yeah
yeah that's probably a good point cuz I
like they don't give you a lot of
analytics around discovery actually yes
I wrote a book about um shipping
containers with my friend Lee yeah yeah
we did that we did a Kickstarter a
couple years ago and Amazon's been I
mean we were immediately like on there
afterwards because we we spent the like
the extra Kickstarter money buying more
books
yes and so it's been super easy to sell
and I don't really know like if we would
have captured fewer sales because we
weren't on Amazon because that discovery
wise like I think it has like you know
less than 10 reviews so I don't feel
like we're getting sales that way
interesting yeah see
I see what you're saying so if it's like
if you're selling something on Amazon
what you the customer will also see
other products that are comparable which
means that customers might get directed
to your competitors products and if it's
not something that's like heavily
reviewed there is no incentive for the
customer to buy your product versus
another product that's been on Amazon
for longer that has more reviews that's
interesting yeah I I think Amazon is
great for generic purchases but it's
really like you don't see Amazon making
funny jokes on Twitter as a corporate
account like you don't see anyone
tagging Amazon in their Instagram posts
it's just that people in their free time
don't enjoy like it's not a brand that
people think about or talk about it's
just generic convenient and pragmatic
thing but it's not this emotional thing
at least I'm not attached to do you
think that like Amazon will like
completely like take over all these
prepackaged meal kits now like is that a
thing that's actually brand
differentiated or not
so yesterday I saw one of my friends
post on Twitter that normally he would
never like make this peach paste sauce
for dinner but because blue apron sent
him a kid with peaches in there and a
recipe for like whatever peach dish he
was making it and he was loving it
that's why he loves blue apron because
it gets him out of like just cooking the
same thing every day and cooking
something special in the same amount of
time I don't know if Amazon if like blue
apron is differentiated enough but it
seems like people get a homey feel from
using blue apron products I don't know I
mean look at all the copycats right yeah
like they're in every vertical so I mean
maybe they're just two different markets
and so yeah like personally I am way too
pragmatic I just get my groceries I cook
what my mom taught me to cook
okay cui I might I might be that rung
target audience here well then what
about all the way what are you story
like blue apron when they when they sent
you stuff and it's like one egg kind of
packaging and that the egg is labeled
egg and I'm like I know this is an egg I
don't know why stupid it does make you
feel a little gross when you're like I
think Trader Joe's for me at least is
like the worst of them
you know like everything's in a little
plastic bag and so I into apartment a
couple years ago and I had bought so
much from Amazon that I was taking out
the recycling that day and I actually
felt nauseous like as I was breaking
down all these Amazon boxes but talking
about recycling the other trend that I'm
seeing in e-commerce is peer to peer
selling that seems to be on the rise
again people selling out if their own
closets if we look at I don't know
Poshmark vented Macari eBay whatever
those are called or even Facebook
marketplace like we're stuff especially
it seems like young women and mothers
selling like used items and getting a
lot of fun out of that Plus having the
personal connection with a seller so
like selling out of their own closets
telling the story about when they bought
this item modeling this item themselves
yeah it's funny and then you like they
put a handwritten card in there it's an
interesting so that is becoming more
popular I yes we have a lot of those on
our on our platform like using ship
ownership for their second half
marketplaces and that's a fast growing
segment I think it's still a very small
segment and overall ecommerce of course
yeah but um it's it's a growing one what
about all those like box of the month
clothes is still a thing yeah I mean
there's a box for everything yeah yeah
you can get well you name it yeah yeah
um as surprise dad just loot crate for
instance is a big one that we're just
looking at and that's it's a gamer
specific box and then they're like sex
toy boxes like really everything anyway
I think it's the convenience and as soon
as you subscribe to something it is hard
to unsubscribe that's the other
component there so and then people like
to be surprised like if you're already
paying for it it's like you gave them
your credit card number once and then
you forget that it's a recurring payment
and then you're just getting the Box
everyone that you're making you so happy
of that adrenaline and Happiness
endorphin rush oh and then get one for
your doc and your cat as well yeah it's
crazy yeah I think a lot of those people
are like infamously known for you know
like you can sign up online and then you
have to call in to cancel it's like that
kind of stuff are you are those on the
rise though no sir and then you're
they're giving you the first box for
free but you have to give them your
credit card number then they try to
automatically afterwards yeah classic
yeah I don't know if they're on the rice
still it feels like something that was
on the rise two or three years ago and
now it's like dabbling but it's not I
don't see it going away but I'm also
seeing that some of these box companies
they're also in addition to the to the
monthly box thing they're they're
selling having an e-commerce store where
you can buy these items one-off mmm okay
then are you noticing any other trends
because now I'm just realizing that like
by being at the hub of all this you kind
of like see what businesses are like
taking yes so we saw all of these segues
being show like oh wait segue sir
no same thing for me yes the hoverboards
we saw them being shipped and then the
USPS or the shipping providers actually
had an extra regulation for hoverboards
not allowing them to be shipped anymore
because they were dangerous and explodes
we also saw like a huge rise in vape
company signing up that seemed to be a
thing then there was this couple months
where people loved sending each other
just like like joke items though is this
when you when you open the package it's
like glitter coming out oh that was you
guys related we weren't selling them we
were just shipping them yeah
okay and then um yes so that was big or
like even had poop in a box I know if it
was real food we just see the name
signing up and really care yeah we don't
really care and then that was that was a
very smart idea just financially like
having a message on a potato it was like
I think $10 to get a potato shipped and
the potato would have your message
written on top of him what we had
multiple of these stories okay so it's
not in a box just has like a label stuck
on it and you guys do that just like
random size whatever whatever I mean
we're so we're just providing the the
technology to print those shipping
labels they tell us size and weight and
to and from address and you get a label
whatever you want a ship as long as it's
like within the legal realm week if you
label you ship it it's fine mm-hmm have
you guys gotten a bunch of money for the
in the fidgets spinner game I think the
fidgets spinners are too small too oh no
yes money because you can put them in a
letter we want to ship something that is
3d ah what about um medical marijuana
has that trend at all I think that is
more like the on-demand delivery so we
we have a couple of stores on our site
that ship like accessories for that yeah
I think one of them is actually YC
affiliated called bill OB they're pretty
big like the Nasty Gal for vaping and
other than like we ship the accessories
but I don't think Mariana is allowed to
be shipped even in California yeah I
think um like there's on demand for that
okay on-demand delivery I was just
wondering if that if that trend was
going like if folks are lobbying now to
like get it like together within the
state oh here's my favorite shipping
fact out of some some like past days
it's still legal to ship an alligator
with the USPS as long as it's smaller
than 20 inches okay alive alive yeah yes
a baby
really yes how do you package an
alligator I have no idea problem we give
you the shipping label for the obviously
it doesn't matter yeah do you guys then
like are you liable for anything like if
what is your problem so its its inner
and our terms of services what you're
allowed to ship on what you're not
allowed to ship and as long as you stick
to the terms and services were we're
fine you're fine but our agreements with
the shipping providers also are clear
that we're not liable for the things
that our customer ship so every customer
is recognized as a separate customer
with no shipping providers but it's it's
our job to like make sure that our
customers know what the terms and
services are provided by the shipping
provider and so the alligator is on
there the alligator like on your website
maybe and the fine prints know the a
like it's part of the USPS terms and
services the official ones that the
alligator can be shipped as long as it
does not exceed 20 inches okay I'm
wondering like what if it's growing
while it's being shipped depends where
it's being chefs yeah it's like 19 and a
half inches and it takes like five days
though that's really funny what about
all these other companies like I once
shipped my bike from Colorado to
California are these companies like
doing it on their own are they just
setting up like basically just this
front page and then they just ship with
you like are you seeing all these like
basically SEO targeted shipping you know
it's like shape your bike shape your
camera or whatever there are two aspects
to that question like if you ship
something let's say from Colorado to
California I bet they're shipping
providers that are like that are focused
on shipping from Colorado so for
instance here in San Francisco in
California a regional shipping provider
is called on track on the other coast
site or regional shipping providers
called laser ship then there is another
one called gso that's here so for each
region their shipping providers that are
specialized on that particular region
and then they're also shipping providers
for
just on like certain segments in in wine
country we have a lot of shipping
providers that are just focused on
shipping wine and by having them on our
platform were like also allowing our
customers to discover shipping providers
that they wouldn't discover otherwise
because it's such a niche product and
it's not not only about the discovery
it's also yes we're shipping a couple
like we're having wine as one of our
segments but what that e-commerce store
really want to go through the trouble of
integrating a specialized wine shipping
provider and if we already have it then
they just need to enable it and like are
able to save money there your question
about whether like there are shipping
providers that are specific for bikes I
think everything that's less than I
think was 71 pounds the normal shipping
providers can ship and then there are
other shipping providers that are
focused on less and truckload and stuff
but it's likely that these that these
items these SEO pages are just giving
the traffic to to normal shipping
providers okay yeah man I got burned
with that to shipping car tires hmm
total sucker for this well next time you
can just ask me yeah yeah do you guys do
you deal with insurance too yeah we
don't thing we have insurance on top of
ship oh oh and the other thing that is
quite interesting about shipping is the
tracking component so because like
shipping affects conversion rates a
decreases cart abandonment if you have
the right shipping options or the right
shipping costs but then after you ship
your item out it doesn't stop there like
customers are wondering what is
happening to their item along the way so
they want to be like engaged with
tracking numbers who want to be
proactive about that versus having
customers write in because if someone
rides in you need a live person to like
respond to that if you just sent them
push notifications with our web hooks or
with yeah well with the web hooks about
package husband ship package arrived at
this facility package will get your
house today
like customers are going to think about
your product whenever they get a
notification like that and then if you
send them like suggestions about what
else they could buy in your store
the same email it can get them back to
your website mmm do you advise people on
like best policies for handling returns
because I often find that like all of
these companies feel like it's their
duty to like innovate on new ways to
like have you send things back to them
and it's like it's the worst yeah so
that's another thing that consumers like
take into account before they make a
purchasing decision they want to know if
returns are possible and if like return
shipping is free yeah so I guess I guess
it's there are two perspectives to this
from the end customer perspective it
would be best practice to put a shipping
label right into the box and that
shipping label most likely well like we
provide scan based return labels that
means unless it's being scanned the
merchant is not going to get charged for
it so you can print a shipping label
free of charge and when it scans we will
charge you for it but from the merchants
perspective you want to make the returns
more difficult so that people are less
likely to return their item because once
you return it you need to figure out
what to do with that returned inventory
yes so they're there too there are these
two different perspectives that are
clashing I would say to make it right
like what I do admire about Amazon is
whenever something is not right they
will give you a free item they will give
you free returns and that's that's made
me very happy in the past and I would
just recommend ecommerce stores to do
the same unless they're seeing abuse of
that on their on their website mm-hmm
okay yeah I think yeah the most famous
one is REI I guess like people were
buying things off eBay from like 15
years ago and returning it all right
exactly I mean if you're giving people
an opportunity to like cheap the system
they likely will achieve this okay so
you can make it like a little bit
difficult but it also like you can also
see if you're acquiring or converting
the type of customers that are going to
abuse the system you're likely
converting the wrong type of customers
right you maybe are going after the
wrong target audience hmm meaning like
just too broad or just off
just to rod off or maybe you're having
the wrong messaging on your website that
is attractive to customers who are more
likely to cheat the system
okay gotcha so you guys are now like
what four years old
three and a half three and a half years
old and you're 66 I wish people yeah see
five people how are you feeling like you
know insane it's really unbelievable I
can't I can't believe it we think we got
super lucky that we found a space that
is fast-growing shipping is like tied to
e-commerce growth it's still very
inefficient that technologies aren't
great there there is not that much
competition so it's easy to innovate in
that space and to to write on the
e-commerce growth wave and then just in
terms of people I'm just walking through
the office and there are so many people
there I I need to pinch myself but it's
it's great working with I think working
with my having the right partner has
been super helpful like someone who's a
partner in crime
who can all right like we don't get any
crimes who's like always been working
with me through this for the last three
and half years and then of course having
the right supporters in turn on the
investor side as well yeah who can help
me figure things out we were also able
to hire more senior leadership team last
year so to put the operational
experience in place yeah so then what
are what are you working on personally
like improving so I am always trying to
improve to be like working on how to be
a better manager me my co-founder we got
an executive coach a year and a half ago
and are now working with the coach
that's been phenomenal like
understanding how to manage people how
to motivate people how to give feedback
in a constructive way it's all about
communication that's that's the main
learning from growing the team like
communicating how right because everyone
will say that right you're just like
yeah be empathetic can be nice and
listen to people and I love
like no I would say like the umbrella
term for that is you need to be
effective in your communication and it
really like depending on what that
person's like like I don't like I like
straightforward communication I don't
like a [ __ ] sandwich some people and
that's effective with me but then with
other people you might need to be I
don't know like less like more
empathetic in your communication and
understanding like understanding how to
communicate to whom and then remaining
authentic and being able to be
comfortable with that that's that's like
that's something I'm trying to learn and
improve on the only time the
authenticity is the other important part
like I want to know or I've been trying
to figure out what my personal
leadership style is how I'm most
comfortable communicating and who I want
to be and then be like absolutely
unapologetic that like this is who I am
and I will walk the extra mile to this
extent but I like can't work with just
everyone like you need to yeah it needs
to work on both ends right and so then
when you're when you're hiring you know
executives managers do you kind of like
divide teams based on how they take
input from each other or you just like
hey you you know you're not very good at
dealing with people who like can't
handle this direct communication so I've
been ok so I think what worked for me
very well is to be very proactive about
telling people this is how I communicate
and setting the expectation right that
this is just how I communicate it's not
you it's me and I like yeah making sure
that they know that I communicate like
that to everyone and one of my flaws is
for instance that I call out that I
don't celebrate wins that much I'm
always like looking at the next
milestone and I'm quick to criticize but
I'm not quick to praise and that is that
can be demotivating if people think it's
them so what I'm trying to tell people
is like this is this is my flaw and I
recognize it and if you're not getting
enough praise please do let me know
because it's not it's not your fault
it's my fault
and then I don't want to put that weight
entirely on me I'm hoping that the
senior leaders my company can meet me
halfway and help me with achieving my
goal of like praising people more as
well so when I'm like not doing it let
me know and I will change but please
like speak up and let me know and so
then like this this comes out by having
conversations with a coach or do you
like journalists when you're like oh
here's what I'm struggling with it comes
out like the the coach observes how I
talked with my co-founder we go oh they
like hang out and no I mean like Simon
and I we go together to the coach okay
so we sit on that couch together it's
like couples therapy we're co-founders
and then I think like I am fairly
self-aware about like my shortcomings as
well and then I get that feedback from
the leaders we have 360 reviews and then
we bring in those reviews to the coach
to this guy's mmm okay inhaling yeah the
most important part is that people
shouldn't be afraid about speaking up or
like bringing in like what they think
could be improved and then making sure
that they understand it's being heard
and either that I say like either that I
acknowledge that this is a shortcoming
and that I want to act on it or that I
acknowledge that this is happening but I
can't act on it because it would be
inauthentic for me to do mmm
inauthentic and like that's not
something that's on how you would
address that problem I'm not sure what
you mean Oh like if it's just if it
doesn't work with my personality and I
need to change just fundamentally Who I
am to be able to like act on that
feedback I guess it would be I just
don't want to pretend to be someone else
at work every single day
mmm does that make sense it makes sense
I just wonder like what what is
something that you would be like I'm
trying to think of a good example that
doesn't sound hyperbolic it's like oh I
can't be nice to that person because I
hate that
this is enough antics for me no no no
it's um let me think about it it's like
on a to stick with that that example
about praise so I've been trying to hire
people who are complementary to me who
are like war you know who to myth comes
more natural to praise people who have a
more celebratory nature and then with
that they're able to balance me out and
we have people like that in the company
and then instead of me having to like
always pop the champagne bottle which
would feel so awkward to me have someone
else do it but I stand there I clap and
I'm approving this just like nod nicely
exactly do you uh do you read books or
any of that stuff has has that been like
inspiring for you yeah the favorite book
that I just read a couple months ago was
Shu doc by the night founder okay that
was I mean it wasn't written by him it
was a biography about the founder okay
so good such a great bug Kathy yes it's
the best part about it was or like what
would what inspired me the most was like
back then when he founded the company
communication wasn't like it would there
was no cloud no internet like
communication was a synchronous he had
to write an email write a letter to his
manufacturer in Japan and would take
like three weeks to get there and he was
sitting like back in I think it was in
Oregon or somewhere where where he was
based and just wait for a response for
like an entire month and it was mission
critical and it took them a month to get
a response yeah it's a very interesting
like looking at it from a perspective of
building a start-up in a pre-internet
time mm-hmm-hmm who are the other people
that have inspired you hmm
I am so I'm German originally I'm quite
inspired by Merkel as well she's a tough
leader is that why I like yeah I'd say
like she has her principles that she
sticks to and then she is able like to
yeah she just does not compromise on her
own principles and then the other thing
that I admire about her as like
she does not conform to the stereotypes
of how a female leader should be like
she were she does not need to she
doesn't feel like she needs to smile a
lot or like put on a lot of makeup or
look anything like what the stereotype
should be and she's very comfortable and
authentic with that yeah I mean do you
enjoy talking about the female founder
stuff are you yes and no so like I mean
I think I would like it more to be just
a conversation about like being the best
founder or being a very good founder of
versus being a very good female founder
because in the end the market really
doesn't care if you're a female founder
or not the market cares about your
product like I could we could offer the
best female founded shipping company if
there is a better like male founded
shipping company we're not gonna
yes so that's that's the that's the one
side and then I think I would love the
conversation to be more about like to be
a little bit more about female
accomplishments as well versus just
being about the downsides of women in
tech because there are a lot of great
female accomplishments to point out and
they sometimes get under in these like
stories that are that are mostly
harassment related these stories need to
be told don't get me wrong they should
be told people should be like held
accountable for that people should know
what's happening out there but then I
would love to balance the conversation
out as well with like in by encouraging
to encourage other women to join the
industry like there there are good
stories that are happening as well mhm
yeah I think it it kind of like scares
certain people from even joining exact
conversation oh it's always negative
like I'm never gonna comment yeah yeah
cool
alright so we've been here for like 45
minutes now so what do you advise for
people like you're just getting started
like maybe even yeah like b2b like less
like sexy stuff yes
so I I love the like less sexy space
yeah because you're solving a real pain
point you're like more in the background
it's it's not sexy at parties people
aren't excited about my shoving stories
they're like shut up but so it's it's
mission critical to every business and I
just love building something that you
know is solving a real pain point that
is a must-have not a nice to happen and
you can actually charge for that as well
every customer that we have on Shippo is
a paying customer there is no free trial
because because it's shipping there's no
free trial to shipping and the the
lock-in effect there is very strong as
well so I would say like for four
founders just getting started like look
at solving problems that are real
problems that people can't live without
where there is an inefficiency that's
either causing people to spend too much
time which wants money right now and
then any type of infrastructure business
I'm like a big fan of that on the more
general side I would say for us like at
the very beginning like now logistics
and the shipping space is becoming more
interesting to investors at the very
beginning people weren't interested in
in the logistics space and it's just a
lot of like staying remaining persistent
and then not not giving up like always
tweaking the pitch making sure that you
know that after every no you figure out
another way to pitch it and find the
next investor to pitch it to I think we
wouldn't be here if we if we if we
weren't that persistent it's about
remaining persistent but about the right
things like sometimes you need to know
when to give up but you need to be
flexible about like how you push things
and who you push it to mm did you have
any like kind of mental models you were
using to figure out what was important
because you I think you I mean it's the
more important thing is building the
company like the raising money is kind
of like you can build a company without
raising money yeah yeah it's a business
like yes everything doesn't have to be a
start-up but how did you figure out what
was the important stuff to focus on at
the very beginning it was mostly
customer feedback like we were able to
develop a bigger vision a little later
in the process when we had the money to
be able to sit down and take a step back
and develop a bigger vision at the
beginning was like this is the main pain
point that our customers are facing and
we want to solve this pain point for our
customers and we need to build X to
solve it and for that we need to raise X
amount of money and then we placed it in
a bigger context like why is shipping
important in the e-commerce context so
we were able to tell that story about
the size of the market the growth of the
market the growth of e-commerce to
investors to give them like the big
picture as well if it's a fast growing
space there is a problem customers are
liking what we filled and by the way
this is what we filled and this is what
we what we see the opportunity to be
like in the big picture and this is how
fast we're growing okay cool
well then I think my last question is a
favorite place to go running in San
Francisco oh okay so I normally run in
Golden Gate Park from I live in Lower
Haight so from Lower Haight into Golden
Gate Park and then if possible
I do like running at Crissy fields as
well but it's more of a drive yeah more
of it okay are you training for anything
no I that's the one thing I do for fun
and for fun only if I like yeah if I
sign up for a marathon or something like
that I would get into this competitive
thing perfect cool all right thanks for
coming on thank you
you